dude it's our birthday week brah dude
didn't older fighting off Corona happy
birthday man
I know happy birthday first man yep and
you're right after me dude well your
birthday was yesterday no my birthday
[Laughter]
[Music]
may be awesome for you it's a wine bag
and that card open the card you thought
there was food in there brother
hot fries gotta get right to it you
thought it was a bad read it yeah come
on now this says happy birthday booby
boy thanks for supporting thing thanks
for being supportive and introducing me
to new friends like Kat and chin and
Chappell
I've never had a black friend before
hope hope hope hope your hope your is
next year a good one
grammar here boss hope your is next year
a good one whatever that's what you
wrote here what's your hope your is next
year okay look eighth dwarf spell e okay
hope your is next year a good one
now that's not what it says I swear on
my life thanks reducing new people and
their had a black friend before hope
door is next year a good sleep easy read
e that is Reedy dude
let your mom spell check for you right
the boy card why did you set this tone
it's a small card again through getting
through the card Brendan read it
am i off I made the black friend thing I
knew you did it reads perfectly clear
yep you're right hope your is next year
a good one okay rope is a little
off-roading for your CTE that's all that
was I knew what you meant I get it I get
boring when you wrote that I was in the
van dude had to get that ordered bro had
to buy the bottle man that's cool give
you a side eight-by-ten of me
hey Darwin way hard to get the double XL
[Laughter]
killer merge life I can how are you
happy for you know Oh what is this man
some dope kicks man I told y'all to get
some dope kicks rock on stage ain't
nothing like a fresh pair of Jays these
Riddler's huh the pine greenies yeah
yeah if you feeling frosty you can you
can put the red laces in which I like
but Wow black it was crisp that's
Christmas Footwear huh I give to George
wait what what that's a double pop that
counts dude oh there's two of them damn
[Laughter]
awesome one wasn't good enough
oh this is frosty is fun and we got you
something too cat new car well last week
you guys were talking about a cookie
cake
am I gonna break my diet for this again
you are I'm sure okay you mean every day
I'm down a pound son are you really no
you look great I was gonna say something
look like that yeah damn mrs. field said
[ __ ] corona and made it and because Wow
and because people hate here and chewing
on mic while you enjoy it we have
another little surprise
enjoy some enjoy some cake hey brother
surprise you flew my mom and if you fool
my mom in from Deborah I'm gonna freak
out I'm gonna freak out dude if you flew
my [ __ ] mom in we're not getting
along right now I'm gonna freak out dude
dude if you flew Patrick in from Hawaii
[Laughter]
[Music]